yo what's up everybody's procedure man
Luigi's here take another Borderlands
the pre-sequel video today I'm gonna be
showing you what I believe to be the
quickest most efficient way of farming
vending machines in Borderlands a lot of
people farm Concordia as the best way to
get farming vending machines and get
Legendary's from the vending machines or
other guns that you might want or
shields or class mods grenades mods but
I believe that the three vending
machines here and out the outfall
pumping station that you see me of the
farming right now I believe that is
definitely the fastest way to farm
vending machines so I'm going to show
you how you get here and I'm going to
compare it to the other methods of
popular methods of farming which is two
different ways to farm the five
Concordia denting machines so hope you
enjoy all right so first thing you're
going to want to do is you're going to
want to head to Virago solitude now you
can either fast travel to here in any
fast travel station or you can go to
Titan flats and I do believe Titan flats
connects to rod ROG over I go I'm
allowed to say that solitude now you're
going to want to go here because the
outfall pumping station where I'm going
to take you to does not have a fast
travel station so this is the only place
that you can get to it from you can see
on the map in the bottom center of the
map there's the exit to the outfall
pumping station this is where you farm
or not necessarily farm kill rks the
giant flying plane armor guy that's one
of the main bosses in the game and you
it's where you're gonna fight him but
you're not gonna fight him you're just
gonna farm the vending machines there
now you can just follow my path I
usually love to run and jump on these
rocks so I can avoid a good chunk of the
enemies since I really am not too
bothered in fighting them at level 50 I
don't need any more XP and I just want
to farm some legendaries so you're gonna
just run over you can hop to this
building get a boost from this jump pad
and that will get you pretty close from
here now it was just a straight shot of
following the path to the door I do now
this method I do like it better or more
ore than any other method then I can
like think of in the games and almost
every
set of vending machines is either before
boss which so that's not too easy to get
to or it's right where you travel to a
place so and almost a ton of places that
you get to you're gonna primarily get to
all fast travel stations and if you go
through the fast travel stations you
have about a two and a half second
animation of that dub that blue pipe
tunnel that takes you uh the bluelux
spawning if you know what I'm talking
about how you spawn in and there's the
get a blue animation of like going
soaring through a tunnel like it happens
if you die also when you respond and
that delays on the time but you see here
since you're just spawning out of an
exit you can go you can eliminate that
two point five animation you see there
was the elevator that would take you
down to arcade five but we're not going
to use that and we're just going to
start farming legendaries so this is
what I believe to be the best place in
the map to farm legendaries a little bit
in a little bit I will show you the
vending machine hit ups per minute that
I found from each spot and to prove to
you that's high this is the fastest in
the game that so far that I've tested I
believe it is the fastest so if you
don't know what bending farming is and
you've gotten this far in the video then
good job but I'll tell you it's
repeatedly going to vending machines in
hopes of getting a legendary or some
other item weapon it is new to
pre-sequel in that you can get
legendaries at these vending machines in
previous Borderlands you cannot to my
knowledge
so let's get to the nitty-gritty of why
I chose this is the best spot you'll see
me getting three different legendaries
from this that however from this one
spot that however is completely
irrelevant to what I'm gonna say in in
most of this video since right now I'm
just proving the best position to do the
set so you see this place I ran about
forty three times and at about three
bending machines a hit I hit about one
hundred twenty nine vending machines it
took me about fourteen seconds per run
most of these are sped up by two however
the first run of this
kept it at the normal speed I'm going to
do that for each spot I look at and so
129 vending hits in over the course of
ten minutes I did this a testing period
of ten minutes gave me 12 point 9 V p.m.
as I call them or vending vendors per
minute so I'm going to judge each spot
all of the BPM too so we have a unified
system of judging each place so the
first then the first the place that I'm
saying we should all farm at the most
the best place to do it at is the RK 5
place and that has a rate of 12 point 9
V p.m. now you're gonna see I'm at
Concordia and I'm first gonna do it from
the spawning from the fast travel
station which does have the spawn time
however you can farm you see this
doorway you can farm going from there
which eliminates that but first we're
gonna be looking at it with the slowed
slowing down animation so I ran this I
ran this for only 5 minutes since I knew
it was going to be slower than the
original Titan flats to here so I did 5
minutes I had eight runs eight runs at
with five vendors per run gives me 40
vendors hit I did over five minutes so
40 vendors over 5 minutes it gives me a
BPM of 8 so that's 8 BPM that is 4.9 BPM
less than that's all there's about 5 V
p.m. less then you would get going from
out the outfall pumping station so that
this is definitely though I feel like
this is the most common way going from
the fast-travel station this is what I
normally did if I ever found legendaries
from the vending machines I never did
too heavy of farming as in if I did I
would find this but that is definitely
the the most common way that I think and
I think it's not that good so now you
see if you go to the Titan flat store if
you come back out you can save and quit
you'll always spawn from the Titan flat
store so this gets rid of that delayed
spawn time you're gonna see the normal
time it takes me to do this nor
it takes me from train flats if I go
about 20 per seconds per run
I saw sorry I forgot selling on the
previous run that was about 33 seconds
so even if I take out the warp zone time
just to go off plane route traffic that
still took thirty point five seconds per
run which is 2.5 seconds faster than
this the firm train frets so I did this
one for about ten minutes since it was
the more efficient of the Concordia
farms and I got in 10 minutes I got 21
runs so about half of what I did at the
other spot and I got five vendors per
run so 21 times five is a hundred and
five vendors one hundred five vendors
divided by ten minutes gives me a V PM
of ten point five so this is a lot
better than going the than the BPM from
doing the Concordia fast travel so if
you're gonna if you want to stand good
Cordia definitely do it this way since
it takes like I don't know 30 seconds
then not even it takes like 15 seconds
to go to the train flat store and come
back out it's a lot better way than fast
travel but still it's ten point five bv
p.m. of the I forgot the name outfall
pumping station I believe is twelve
point nine so twelve point nine - ten
point five that is still a one point
four vpm difference so I'm still getting
one and a half vendors every minute so
every two minutes I'm getting three more
vendors in the alcohol pumping station
than I would in any form of doing it in
Concordia alright so that is about it
for this video the you can see here's
the math of what I did the outfall
permutation ends up with twelve point
nine the train door Concordia ends up
with a ten point five and the fast
travel Concordia ends up with an eight
vpm the o-p-s outranking all of its
competitors so do hope you guys have
enjoyed this video it did take a while
to make so appreciate if you did like it
then make sure you let me know in the
comments if you want anything more like
this again let me know and that's about
it so again I hope you enjoyed it and
I'll see you all in the next video peace
out